donc en fait l'âge de 7-8 ans je faisais
du hockey sur glace à l'époque the beat
à clermont ferrand et pour raymond
raisons familiales je suis descendu sur
nîmes et anime pas de patinoire
donc pas de patinoire voilà aussi
commencé le judo on promet que la ban
nîmes à l'âge de 8 ans 8-9 ans 1,5 ha
d'agrumes fois les moins de 90 kg
thierry fabre est aujourd'hui l'un des
quatre meilleurs français
début novembre lors des championnats de
france le nouveau gagné quatre combats
par ippon le chaos du judoka pas dans le
cinquième et la place du champion de
france de très très peu face à david
bauzou clients son coéquipier et
principal rival aujourd'hui thiery est
dans la course aux jo
un seul garçon par catégorie poids
pourra représenter la france en août
prochain à athènes
c'est à l'issue des championnats
d'europe en janvier et du tournoi de
paris en février que lé sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france devront faire leur
choix mais qu'elle était pour l'instant
c'est surtout l'aspect physique un petit
peu tactique aussi au niveau technique
c'est là où
je dois faire l'effort pour progresser
et faire la différence justement
pourquoi ces numéros le point fort de
tiris est également que sa précocité
à 21 ans physiquement musculairement il
est aujourd'hui arrivé à maturité
alors que d'habitude dans sa catégorie
poids les champions sont au mieux de
leurs forces vers 27 28 ans un avantage
supplémentaire dans la course pour ses
premières olympiades qui sans aucun
doute ne seront pas les dernières